I wouldn't know because I blacked out
for the entire period yeah I was just
Blake was just behind him awkwardly
manipulating my body
it was amazing her son is a deadpool fan
he brought him the Deadpool mask look at
that I mean that's kind of amazing it is
kind of like like are you at her concert
where is this I'm trying to figure out
where I thought it was on a cruise ship
yeah crucial spoiler alert we're having
dinner at our apartment
how are your plans for yet another
Deadpool in the French oh yeah yeah
we're working on it right now with the
whole team we're over at Marvel now yeah
I could use the big leagues all of a
sudden it's kind of crazy so yeah we're
working on it
and you're also working on with the rock
on a new film like that
[Music]
I know right welcome back everyone its
Charlie we have big Deadpool three
Marvel news so Ryan Reynolds is doing
the talk show circuit explaining what's
going on with Deadpool 3 we know a
little bit about what's going on behind
the scenes so we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos
there's gonna be a whole bunch of big
Marvel stuff happening real soon
we're doing a new Marvel Amazon giveaway
- all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave all your
predictions about Deadpool 3 on the
video so if you're wondering why Ryan
Reynolds is wearing an ugly sweater
going on the morning talk show circuit
he's just promoting that Netflix movie
that he made with Michael Bay I'm not
gonna be talking about that that's not
really relevant to what's going on with
Deadpool 3 it's just that while he's
going around doing this everyone's
asking him what's going on with him at
Marvel are you gonna make Deadpool 3 of
course he's going to make it he's been
talking about it for a while now the
reason why he's doing this wearing the
ugly sweater from last year is because
it's a big callback to the prank war
that he's been having with Hugh Jackman
that goes back to the first Deadpool
movie it's funny how no matter what he
does it all goes back to Deadpool
somehow but the really important stuff
in all this is that he's just explaining
how they've been actively working on
Deadpool 3 inside Marvel so when he says
they're working on it right now he's
talking about his inner circle
production team which right now is
mostly just the writers from the first
Deadpool movies Rhett Reese and Paul
Wernick they've also been talking about
what's going on with Deadpool at Marvel
now in Deadpool 3 all good stuff though
the only people that have been kicked
off the Deadpool team since Marvel got
control those characters again are some
of the upper-level Fox producers that
have moved on to other projects because
Kevin Feige is now producing Deadpool 3
himself and when I mean they're making
it inside Marvel obviously
metaphorically they're making it under
the Marvel umbrella because Marvel
controls all the Fox x-men Fantastic
Four characters now but it also means
literally inside the Marvel offices down
the hallway from Kevin Feige you
probably remember the stories that the
Russos and the writers from Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame told
about how they had a giant conference
room that was literally down the hallway
from Kevin Feige just plastered
wall-to-wall with all kinds of crazy
charts and plans to keep track of those
two movies when they were busy writing
the actual movies the
and why a lot of the Marvel movies get
written that way is so that Kevin Feige
can actually physically walk down the
hallway and poke his head into all the
different movies writers rooms as
they're being written and give them
notes you also may remember earlier this
year Ryan Reynolds dropped a funny
Deadpool three Marvel phase 5 teaser for
the anniversary of the date that he
leaked the original Deadpool test
footage from the first film at the time
it was kind of hard to tell if he was
just having fun on his own or if he was
actually trying to imply that he'd
already worked out a deal with Kevin
Feige on how they'd work on Deadpool 3
everything is just a little bit
different now that they're under
Marvel's supervision but all the things
that Kevin Feige in the big executives
Marvel and Disney have said have been
good things they don't want to change
Deadpool or anything like that within
the Deadpool movies and they also want
to find a way to use him inside the
traditional MCU movies like the big
Avengers films eventually there's a
little bit of nuance to that because
you're not gonna be seeing him dropping
f-bombs all over a pg-13 Avengers movie
but they did say that they would allow
them to make r-rated Deadpool films
while they're with Marvel I did a whole
easter egg video about this here but his
basically Ryan Reynolds acting like
Deadpool himself was trying to solve the
mystery as to who leaked the Deadpool
test footage all the names of the people
on the board here are people that were
involved in the making and development
of the original Deadpool movie including
some of the Fox executives but if you
guys didn't know it was actually Ryan
Reynolds himself that leaked that test
footage we have no idea how that
happened but I promise you I'm looking
into it because initially Fox wasn't
gonna make the movie the test footage
was created back in 2011 but it was
around the time Green Lantern came out
and after that movie bombed right after
the 2009 Wolverine Origins debacle
happened Fox was just a hard pass on any
kind of r-rated Deadpool film but Ryan
Reynolds and Tim Miller thought that
they could do the character justice so a
couple years later at Comic Con in 2014
after the project had kind of stalled
out and the test footage had been
sitting on a shelf on a hard drive for a
couple years Brian Reynolds leaked the
footage on purpose you all probably
remember it blew up huge everyone loved
it and it sort of controlled the
conversation at Comic Con that year that
was the big thing and within a few days
Fox greenlit the original Deadpool movie
and they were off to the races so this
just come
rates that anniversary while also
teasing the new Marvel version of
Deadpool 3 like he says in the little
caption here 5 year plan 5 phase plan as
in Marvel phase 5 right now the best
scenario for when they would actually
release Deadpool 3 is probably 2022 like
if you look at all these dates here for
the untitled movies that will be after a
black panther to which we know is coming
out May 2022 which actually seems like
that might wind up being the first true
Marvel movie with x-men fantastic four
characters deeply integrated into the
plot because the rumor is as the Doctor
Doom is gonna be the main villain a
black panther - there is an untitled
Marvel movie scheduled for October 2022
that would probably be where they
released Deadpool 3 and as for the story
of Deadpool 3 the characters and how it
fits into the MCU movies the biggest
thing is the Kevin Feige the Disney CEO
in the Deadpool 3 writers have all said
that they're still gonna let them do it
as an r-rated Deadpool movie but the way
it's probably going to work because they
do want Deadpool inside MCU movies
eventually - crossing over with the
other mainstream Avengers characters is
that when he appears in the mainstream
Marvel films like an Avengers film he'd
have to be a pg-13 version of himself
but he can be as crazy and hardcore as
he wants in the r-rated Deadpool solo
films same goes for when other Marvel
characters show up inside the Deadpool
r-rated solo films like they're not
gonna let Chris Evans be Captain America
or Robert Downey jr. show up as Iron Man
in an r-rated Deadpool film being super
hardcore like the Hulk isn't gonna show
up and start ripping Deadpool and half
all of a sudden but the Deadpool people
now have access to all the Marvel
characters so remember in the first ed
Poole film how they traded a lot on
x-men humor
he went to the x-mansion and complained
because the movie was so low-budget they
couldn't afford big mainstream x-men
characters they made all the jokes about
how the big a-list x-men characters
didn't want to have anything to do with
him which is why you had the lesser
characters like colossus and negasonic
teenage warhead coming to deal with him
now that he's inside the MCU you just
had to picture him going up against say
like a C or B list Marvel villain and
then complaining about how the Avengers
don't want to help him out because
they're either all dead or retired like
in the case of Hawkeye like he made all
the Wolverine jokes at the beginning of
Deadpool - about him
dying in a Logan imagine him doing the
same thing with Iron Man Robert Downey
jr. wouldn't come on screen himself but
he could trade on a lot of Iron Man
jokes
he could also trade on a lot of
spider-man Tom Holland jokes but they
couldn't have Tom Holland come on screen
that would involve like a completely
separate deal with Sony - which is why
you probably won't see spider-man inside
a Deadpool movie anytime soon and even
though Black Panther 2 seems like it
might be the first genuine big Fantastic
Four crossover you have to remember that
there was a version of Deadpool 2 that
Tim Miller was working on before he left
the project which was going to have the
thing in a bunch of Yancy Street stuff
going on during it instead of the
juggernaut stuff I don't know that that
would have been better but it would have
been fun to see some Fantastic Four
stuff given how badly the last Fantastic
Four movie went seriously I'm so excited
for Kevin Feige smart version of
Fantastic Four we've in rock bottom with
that franchise so many times that
there's nowhere to go with those
characters but up so everyone let me
know in the comments thinking about all
that stuff what do you want them to do
with the Deadpool solo films that are
still going to be r-rated which B and C
lists Marvel villains do you want them
to include in that now it would be fun
to see some mainstream Avengers but I'm
only expecting them to be making jokes
about some of the dead Avengers
characters remember the montage that
they did at the beginning of spider-man
far from home just a really funny jokey
way of referencing all the big stuff
that happened during Avengers endgame it
would be funny to see them reference
something like that inside Deadpool 3
even if it's only just a couple seconds
and a quick joke you may have also seen
Kevin Feige did a really big panel
recently for Marvel phase 4 talked a lot
about Doctor Strange - so I will do a
breakdown video for that stuff in the
next day or so but leave all your Marvel
video requests in the comments below and
post all your Deadpool 3 predictions on
the video everyone click here for my
Mandalorian episode 8 finale video and
click here for my last really big black
widow trailer breakdown in Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you